[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Çok teşekkür ediyorum sizi böyle
ağlatmak için değil aslında
güldürmek için gelmiştim bu programa
davet edildiğim için özellikle Çok
teşekkür ediyorum yetkililere
şimdi Zaten hepimiz malumunuzdur müzik
her zaman
antik yıllardan beri Özellikle de
Osmanlı döneminde her zaman bir Şifa
unsuru oluştur müzik
Osmanlı'nın özellikle buna uygun çok Bu
anlamda çok özel çalışmaları var mesela
ilk şifahane
Bursa'da kurulmuş ve seneleri çok önemli
bir Şifa halimiz var gelininizde
külliyesinde
Fatih şifahanemiz var Edirne şifahanemiz
var ve buralarda
Özellikle de bu makamların özellikleri
takip edilip
biraz daha iyi geliyorsa
Bu yöntemle birçok hastalık tedavi
edilmeye çalışılmış
mesela
Rast makamı huzur veren
Mutluluk veren Neşe veren bir makam
olması ile biliniyor
rast makamında bir eser Dinlediğiniz
zaman bu söylediklerimi hatırlarsınız
sence iyi geldiği biliniyor Bunları kim
tayin etmiş elimizde
İbni Sina'nın ve Farabi'nin yazılı
kaynakları mevcut hangi makamın hangi
özelliği iyi geldiğinden
makamı akıl hastalıklarına ve baş
ağrısına iyi gelirmiş
ama kelime anlamı da zaten Aşıklar
demektir
Aşk ve mistik duyguları tetiklenmiş
Peki neyi konusunda Şifa olduğunu
neresinde zaten
sizde dinledikten sonra biraz
hüzünlendiğini duygulanız neyin sesi
başlı başına bir Şifa Aslında bunu şöyle
Teknik bir özelliği olduğu düşünülüyor
bir süre
gr enstrüman Aslında içinde su var
ve ses de suda titreşen bir şey yani ses
suyu titreştirme özelliğine sahip ve
bizim vücudumuzun da yüzde yetmişi 60'ı
70 yaklaşık sudan oluştuğuna göre
bu kadar etkileyici seslerin insan
vücuduna titreştirilmemesi etkilenmemesi
mümkün değil ne özelliği de itibarıyla
gerçekten dünyada
insanı birinci derecede etkileyen çok
özel sese sahip bir enstrüman ben de çok
şükür bu enstrümanı icra edebildiğim
için çok mutluyum
ev tarihsel bilgi vermeye gelmedim
Aslında
deneyimlerimi aktarmak istiyorum
özellikle Uzun yıllardan beri ne
kocaları yapıyorum
ve yaş Hayal türü meslek
din dil ırktan öğrenci mi oldu ve çok
güzel tecrübeler edindim
neyin insan üzerinde yarattığı en önemli
etki nedir diye soracak olursanız
öğrencilerimden aldım tecrübelere göre
sakinleştirmesi huzur vermesi
diyeceksiniz ki sen o kadar Yalın Ne
yapıyorsun huzurlu bir insan
mısın
Sakin misin Hayır dünyanın en iyi
Taraklı insanlarından bir tanesi ney
hala beni tedavi edebilmiş değil
ama şöyle şeyler yapalım biliyor musunuz
zaman içerisinde mesela çok ağır bir
Astım hastası olan bir kadın öğrencim
vardı
dedi ki; Ben ne üflemek istiyorum ama
Kadın da çok ciddi bir problem var Nefes
alırken bile içerideki sesi
duyabiliyorsunuz
astım hastalarında öyle bir ses geliyor
ve ileri derecede
ki yani isterseniz Neyi
istemeyebilirsiniz Yani bunun için bir
zorunuz Yok hayır dedi Doktorum da Karşı
Çıktı Bende de hem sizi dinledim çok
seviyorum sizi ve neyi üflemek istiyor
öğrenmek istiyorum ve yaklaşık bir yıl
boyunca kadına ders yaptık ve İnanır
mısınız o ağır ilaçlarını yavaşça
azaltmaya başladı ve doktoru da çok
şaşırmıştı bu duruma ve ben de dedim ki
yani
tıba bir katkımız var ne derse verirken
Hem ne derse veriyoruz hem de tıpta bir
katkıda bulunuyoruz Bu benim
güzel bir tecrübeydi
ve
zaman içerisinde mesela çok sinirli her
söylenene ters cevap veren her surede
muhalif bir öğrencim vardı Onunla da
yaklaşık bir 6 ay çalıştıktan sonra
Gittikçe daha sakin daha dingin kendini
böyle akışa bırakan bir ruh haline
büründüğünü gördüm
şöyle de enteresan şeyler oldu hani Şifa
Evet huzura Şifa ama dostluğa da şifa
oldu Ne zaman içerisinde nasıl biliyor
musunuz
iki tane öğrencim var İkisi de diyor ki
ben Ataşehir'de oturuyorum
alış içerisinde böyle çok da Konuşkan
insanlar değiller birisi diyor ki ya
diyor Hocam Gizem abartmada birisi kaval
çalıyor galiba diyor O da diyor Evet
diyor ya galiba kaval çalıyor birisi var
sonra hocam ya bu bizim kattan geliyor
diyor Ben diyor çalıyorum
bakıyor açılıyor diyor Allah Allah
diyorum Sonra Konu nereden geldi
anlamadım
günün sonunda şunu öğrendik İkisi de
aynen farkında oturuyor kocaman büyük
Siteler var
asansörün sağ tarafındaki koridorun
ucunda oturuyor birisi asansörün sol
tarafında gözünde oturuyor
görüyorsunuz komşuluk
ilişkisi de bu durumu o kadar çok
şaşırdılar ki o günden sonra dostu
oldular
Hani aslına bakarsanız bir kamış parçası
gördüğümüz şu ne kadar
dünyanın en itidayı Görünümlü
enstrümanlarından bir tanesi
ama elimize alacağız sanat yapıyoruz ve
Şifa dağıtıyoruz
kendi kendine de Şifa oluyor çalanların
arasında
bu
örnekten sonra
ne üfleyince
diyafram kontrolü yapmanız gerekiyor
Yani o sesleri uzatmak için kısaltmak
için işte piyano Forte dediğimiz müzikal
terimleri gerçekleştirebilmek için
diyafram kontrolü gerekiyor
hayatında hiç Diyanet romanı kullanmamış
diyaframın nerede olduğunu bilmeyen
insanlar var
güneşe doktorlarla dahil
Ben göğüs profesörü göğüs cerrahıyla
diyafram çalıştığımı hatırlıyorum Yani
Anam döviz profesörü ve bilmiyordu
diyaframını kullanmayı çoğumuz
bilmiyoruz
ve ne üfleyince
nefes almayı öğreniyorsunuz nefes almayı
öğrenmek ne demek gündelik hayatımızda
sindirimizi Öfkemizi
sağlığımızı
her şeyimize duruşumuzu kontrol
edebiliyoruz anlamına da geliyor
Bu anlamda da neyin gerçekten Neyi
öğrenmenin büyük bir
şifası var
şöyle enteresan bir tecrüben var Bir gün
bir televizyon programında
tam çekiyoruz Biz arkadaşlarımızla icra
edeceğiz eserleri şimdiden böyle
mikrofonu çalıyorum çalıyorum işte
diyorum ki biraz tiz ver diyorum pes ver
diyorum falan yönetmenler ses yok
xd dedim Orada mısınız ses yok
hayır dedi Sen çatınca Günahlarım aklıma
geliyor dedim
amacım bu değildi
ama Günahlarım aklıma geliyor ama dedim
bu kötü bir şey değil aynı zamanda
huzurum dedi hani hani fark ettiriyor bu
işte bu ses bana bazı şeyleri dedi
[Müzik]
Ama bu anlamda da bir Şifa olduğunu
düşünüyorum
insanlardan çok bahsettim bir de şunu
örnek vereceğim Bir gün bir çiftliği
olan bir arkadaşım dedi ki ya ucuz
Senden bir şey rica edeceğim benim
çiftliğimde çok inek var
merak ediyorum dedi Neyse size onlara
nasıl bir katkıda bulunacak acaba
adım değil mi
gittim çiftliğim
ineklere
uşşak makamında
Taksim yapmaya başladım ve gerçekten
tehlikeli enteresandı ve sadece benimle
muhatap olmayan bir inek vardı orada
yanıma yaklaştı mö falan böyle bayağı
temas halindeyiz
arabada çok enteresan bir ilişki oldu
yani ve sonradan öğrendim ki gerçekten
süt verimli bir katkıda bulunmuşum
[Müzik]
Tabii 1-2 kilo sütü de o şekilde
bedavaya getirmiş oldum O da güzel bir
katkı oldu benim için
bir daha yaşadım
neyin şimdi mesleğim Gebeli çocuk yaştan
beri sürekli Dünyanın her yerinde
konserler yapıyoruz ve neyin aslında
Sadece bize değil bütün dünyada
insanları etki edip özelliğine de ortak
keşfettim
bizat-ı şahidi olarak
mesela Almanya'da bir konserde bir gün
Alman bir kadın
ağlayarak da oynama sarıldı Ben dedi
hayatımda böyle bir ses duymadım
Hani bu kadar başka bir yerden gelen
fantastik bu kadar
birleştirici bu kadar enteresan bir sesi
olan enstrüman duymadım hayatımda ve
sanki de sen de çalınca Ben yerimden
böyle bir onun beslendim havaya kalktım
Öyle hissettim dedi
şimdi
yer Almanya Hani dini belli dili belli
hiçbir şekilde Fark etmiyor İnanır
mısınız
neyin insanlara etkiliyor olması
Tayvan'da bir film festivalinde
çoğalmaya gittim
ve dedim ki
Onların da böyle çok sevdiği parçaları
çalmaya çalıştım çünkü kanatların
görmemişler Bu nasıl bir flüt diye
bakıyorlar Ben de böyle tarif etmeye
çalışıyorum Sonra şey anlattım işte
malumunuz 13 yüzyılda Hz Mevlana'nın
neye insan-ı Kamil yani olduğun insan
sembolü ile bir değer atfetmiş
olmasından dolayı ne Bizim kültürümüzde
tasavvufi bir anlam içeriyor
Ben bunu anlatmaya çalıştım
Artık İngilizce kendini nasıl
parçaladıysam bunu anlatacağım diye
sanat yönetmeni Adamcağız geldi sahneye
çıktı ve dedi ki Burcu Hanım
sizin kültürünüzü de bu enstrüman yerini
Biz bilmiyoruz
Biz zaten budistiz alha da inanmıyoruz
Ama şunu bilmenizi isteriz ki siz
çalmaya başladıktan sonra bütün salon
sustu
biz bu enstrümanın başka bir dünyadan
ses getirdiğini anladık sizi Biz orada
taşıdığınız duvar için size çok teşekkür
ediyoruz dedi
Ben böyle kalakaldım
yani
Bu benim için gerçekten hem onlara
şifaydı Asıl bu bana şifaydı çünkü bana
bir yetenek verilmiş Biz sanatçılar Hani
hiçbir şey biz yapmıyoruz Aslında bize
verilen yeteneği sergilemekle mükelle
ona ben yaptım dersen orada
Büyük bir suç işlemiş olursun ve kendi
inancıma göre de Allah da bana bir
şekilde cezasını verir diye düşünüyorum
her zaman Dolayısıyla benim o
yorgunluğum
o konseri çalma mücadelem bir amaçla Ben
bir amaca hizmet ediyordum ve o koltuğa
oturduktan sonra o yorgunluğunu adamın
odasıyla unut
Tum ne kadar büyük bir yetenek verilmiş
bana Ben insanlara gerçekten
nefesimle
Şifa dağıtmak üzere buraya gelmiş
gördüğünüz gibi
bir son derece basit bir kamış ama
elinize aldığımız zaman biz sanat
yapıyoruz
balıkla tutulabiliyor
ya da yazlık yerlerde görürsünüz
çatılara böyle bunları böyle yan yana
dizerek
çatı da yapıyorlar
çiçeklerin dibine Ekiliyor
dik dursun diye her anlamda bir Şifa
oluyor ama bizim elimizde
aldı dünyanın en özel
sesleri ve sizin gibi güzel
dinleyicilerin izleyicileri karşısında
icra edebiliyoruz ne mutlu bana
[Alkış]
tam zamanında
Yani bu da size özel İnanır mısınız
Normalde ben hiç susmam
Ben Son olarak size bir parça daha
icraat etmek istiyorum Ve ondan sonra
uzunlarınızdan ayrılmak istiyorum
[Alkış]
[Müzik]